[Music]
if you've ever move out of an apartment
or house chances are you've encountered
one of these boxes it's not surprising
since Home Depot has the largest market
share for moving boxes selling 75
million of them each year home depot
boxes are made exclusively by pratt
industries at five different paper mills
in the US what may surprise you is that
the whole process begins at your front
steps first recycled paper gets picked
up from the city curbs and brought to
the Staten Island paper mill by barge or
truck one thing that is very significant
about our business overall is that we
only make things out of recycled
material we don't make anything at all
on emerging trees then there are six
main steps in turning recycled material
into a corrugated box
so once the recyclable paper has been
unloaded a large crane that comes down
and lifts it and puts it up into the
pulper the easiest way to explain this
is if you think about regular washing
machine where you have an agitator in
the middle we put the recyclable paper
in there and then it's agitated along
with warm water to separate the fibers
out
[Music]
once the paper is broken down into pulp
it goes through several screening and
filtering processes to remove impurities
such as ink plastic rubber and styrofoam
what's left is a very clean raw paper
fiber the raw paper fiber is then
pressed and vacuumed into paper and then
turned into a 35-ton paper roll
[Music]
three sepals of paper are run through a
corgi machine to create a corrugated
board there are two outsides and a wavy
Center the fluted middle is what gives
the boxes there are crush resistance and
stacking strengths the corrugated sheet
is then cut into three different widths
depending on the size of the box and
each box is stamped with Home Depot's
iconic logo lastly the box is glued and
shipped off to be folded into a finished
box arguably one of the most common
things that's just so in the background
no one ever pays any attention to it but
there's almost nothing that doesn't
arrive at your store or your door one
way or the other and some kind of
corrugated box and so you know if you if
you think about people with the rise of
e-commerce it's just becoming more and
more common and so it's great to be able
to do something productive with that and
turn it back into a usable product our
program through the Home Depot saves
about 1.4 million trees a year and then
five hundred and seventy million gallons
of fresh water the recycle process uses
one-third of the amount of water the
regular process would use
you
[Music]